is it the fear of losing or is it the
love of winning i i picked the fear of
losing for sure yeah every game that we
lost pretty much
and i mean it kind of stayed with me
until around the seventh or eighth grade
i would cry it hurt me like
just a little like a loss in the family
you know i wanted to be like my heroes
um i watched michael jordan win a lot of
championships and he was still winning
and i just wanted just a p is just a
taste
just a little just what is it like on
that small level just as that would be a
great saturday
today on the show i have chris bosh
an amazingly accomplished basketball
player he's an 11 time nba all-star
two-time nba champion olympic gold
medalist and he has all these
accomplishments but but truly by the end
of the interview it's like
those are amazing but his attitude and
his perspective
and his his general
general energy is like even more amazing
than his than his statistics and his and
his records he's a really in touch guy
like he's and he has a lot of sight of
himself and he wrote a book called
letters to a young athlete and it just
came out there's just so many so many
valuable aspects of what it took for him
to get there and what he learned along
the way um and also who's in who he
innately is and what made him who he is
so and then we also talked about some
sports so for you sports lovers out
there there's definitely some like cool
like sports chat about like you know
amazing plays and what makes a good and
bad teammate and stories from his from
his career so there's uh there's
something for everyone in here and um
just you know i got done with the
interview and i was like adorable like
chris is a really
just genuine wonderful human being and
he has so many nuggets of wisdom to
offer us so enjoy this interview with
the famous and legendary chris bosh
running into each other on the grid at
austin formula one
like it was such a crazy atmosphere too
like i don't know if i've been in a i
mean obviously i've been in some big
races but man that was pretty
pretty electric and there were so many
people and now we've had the f1 finale
there's so much to talk about um but
what i think was the most um with what i
was surprised by the most is you're
there and you're like you got a big old
fancy camera
and you're walking around like either
you're a photographer or like a really
great like a big fan so which one or is
it both
it's both i'm um
i'm a better fan and photographer
i'm an aspiring photographer that's one
of the things that i've been trying to
do more of uh with my life right now is
to really take a deep dive into the arts
and so ever since i was um done playing
i mean it's kind of like i picked up
where i was in my teenage years when i
made that decision to be like
basketball i still had
you know these other um things in my
life that i love doing
uh photography was one of them i used to
i mean even um
in toronto and my wife and i first met
um i was running around the city at
night with one of my friends me and my
uh me and my friend will and we would
take pictures at night
i was gonna leave yeah i tag along with
them and we go taking pictures and stuff
like that well what do you like to take
pictures of
you know i'm still trying to figure that
out but you know the more i do it of
course my kids i have five children so
as they grow i love just taking pictures
just randomly on random days but things
that happen in real life i guess kind of
uh things from my lens um i've been
you know seeing so many cool
photographers and talking with them and
and a lot of them is just the places and
they go and the people they meet and i
think
that i mean that alone i mean
having a camera on the grid that's kind
of cool i've never done that before i've
been lucky to be on a couple of grids
and that was the first time with the
camera
so are you friends with lewis
and louis um
we met uh man it's been like five or six
years ago five or six years ago and i
was already a racing fan kind of but one
once we met and you know meeting an f1
driver is an anomaly
and um
we actually struck up a conversation
before i knew what he did or who he was
and
yeah it was pretty funny we were
crazy story we were at glastonbury in uh
in england and um we were there to see
kanye which my wife and i and our
friends we were there camping out like
for the whole festival
and um
yeah and kanye was performing and
we were backstage and that's what me and
louis met
what were you talking about
just just
stuff sports and you know the
environment the environment was so crazy
and it was ratcheting up and getting
closer to the show and once he told me
he was an f1 driver then it was like
wow that's so fascinating i've watched
it before but i've never even nascar any
indy car i've never met
any drivers before and we struck up a
conversation about that and
just life in general and then pretty
much i want to say
less than a year later we went to uh
monte carlo to go watch him race we all
me um
me lewis and dwayne wade we uh we all
put in together and got a boat
uh off the coast of miami no
we we had to do it one time that bill
when i got that bill i wasn't a happy
camper but you know
we uh we had a great time
and he won the race it was crazy you
earned your way to those kinds of
experiences but
that's so why do
like what do three
such accomplished athletes
talk about like do you talk is it just
like daily life stuff or do you guys get
into it you gotta talk about like
life and like the challenges and the
[ __ ] that happens and the things
that you have to go through and yeah
craziness that life is like
does it get into like the deep stuff
sometimes that particular trip it did um
and
you know i think more so than anything
we talked about just our stories from
where we come from and and it's so
fascinating just to hear
different stories but they're all kind
of the same the challenges that we all
have to get over um obstacles in the way
on your way to being the best driver
ever you know
um you know his ambitions um because i
think
he still wanted to win more
championships and hopefully
you know break records and stuff like
that but we didn't we didn't talk about
that it was just something about life we
connected on music we talked a lot about
music he's a great musician and you know
he loves
loves making music just like me so we
play the guitar right
yeah i played a guitar you know i'm i
have a lot of friends that
i
you know are multi-instrumentalists so
i've been hanging out with them hoping
uh hoping that some of it rubs off on me
you might play anything
um no not not really i'm gonna push him
i'm gonna push him to pick something up
you know it's interesting
like drums what do you need
um
yeah what could he do you know what we
need you know the front man that takes
his shirt off all the time he would
gladly be that guy
you know
okay i think he did great yeah
yeah yeah the lead singer like okay you
yeah the showman you put on the show and
we'll do the music
[Laughter]
um well i think it's you know it's
always so cool to be able to like be in
those situations with
people that have gone through similar
experiences in life and
and um and i guess that's even what i
found with doing this show is you end up
realizing how much more similar we are
than than than not
and so you know you say like that
there's actually a lot of similar themes
in
your lives growing up
what would you say uh coming you know
people like d wade or lewis hamilton or
you know you've been around some some a
lot of those kinds of people what do you
think like the most common themes are
um about their lives and especially like
writing a book that is you know
letters to a young athlete like i mean
the the there's got to be some common
themes that for sure by the way i got
this um when i was in after i went to
austin to the race i went to
um ryan holliday's painted porsche book
shop
and um
so that's all right
extra even more special than just your
book yeah i have to thank ryan yeah we
went down there a while ago to see his
uh whole operation i think i did his
podcast there and the books had just
came in so
you know yeah that's so cool just to see
your work um in somewhere i mean that's
a success to me i guess for me that was
one of the challenges in writing this
book i wanted to
bring those common themes to light
um because that you know in my success
that's kind of
the thing that i found was that
we can all relate to each other there's
always this moment of truth to where
it's you have to make a decision on what
you're going to do
and then that doesn't mean everybody's
going to believe you there's going to be
a long tough road
you know that that's promised in
whatever goal you're trying to pursue
you know so for me in that reaching um
you know the pinnacle of my goals
winning championships
um being able to do
some great things play with the best
athletes in the world be the best
athlete in the world travel the world
win gold medals i mean you know the
chase goes on um i always say kind of
one of the fascinating things after
about after you accomplish the
championship is
they come out there they sweep up the
confetti
now it's about next season
you know and if you wanted people like
ah you know you don't get the credit
that you feel that you deserve and all
those things so
my thing was just to focus on the
journey
of um of what you're doing
make sure that every day you're working
toward a goal
and that's a good start you know it can
be so many challenges that come your way
and again we all have that in common too
right i mean even for you i mean i could
only imagine you know being
a woman in in race sport like
the things that you have to endure the
challenges that you have to get over and
on top of that everybody is not
going to support you or not going to
believe in you but you can concentrate
on those that do
um you can build a very strong support
system and a very strong team around you
and you know if if that's not the case
if you're not feeling where you're
supposed to be then you know have the
courage to make some changes
i think that's easier said than done
because what that is self-confidence
right of course like it's a little
easier than when it's written it's all
done and we're like wow you know i just
you know i believed in myself it's like
in the moment of course like especially
the people listening that um especially
i think this this will get some you know
younger aspiring athletes and and it's
just like yeah of course it's easier
said than done so
what is it that how do you how do you
get the
confidence or where do you find it where
do you find the confidence to go i'm not
getting the kind of support i need i'm
not hanging around the right kind of
people
i'm not cr having the right discipline
there's a lot of things that go into it
how do you have any awareness and then
like how do you get how do you get to
awareness
i think self-assessment is always a very
um good thing to do i mean you know
sometimes you have to sit um assess your
goals write down your goals if you need
to
um
be honest about where you are
and you know good bad or indifferent
there's still going to be a next step
regardless
um i'm kind of an organized person so
this is just my
kind of what i do but i always kind of
self-assess and see where i'm at how do
i feel
um and you know sometimes that takes
investing time in yourself and i think
you know in the day-to-day
we can get away from that sometimes or a
person can become overwhelmed and they
won't work on what they need to work on
for themselves it'll just be
trying to work on that thing that
everyone thinks it should you know they
should be uh so for me
you know i always just try to keep that
in mind um
you know for me
um
maturing to where i am now i have five
children
like i said before so my first job is
being dad and
i have to make sure that i'm in the
right head space every day
um to be able to talk to them to be able
to
let them know okay this is what we're
doing today we've got to finish school
we've got why
because this is our goal to be educated
to have you know access
and be successful later on in life and
and then really kind of pick up from
there and go from there you know try my
best to stay present
whatever the day brings along
you know try to dive fully into it
well you had a
huge career that
you know i always think about this with
athletes like you don't i don't feel
like you really plan old retirement
there might be like an idea where you go
maybe in a few years maybe i'll play for
like five more maybe three more like
that's kind of the limit of what you
think about when you think about
retiring as an athlete because if you
play or participate at the level that
you you need that you want to and that
you deserve to play at and participate
at
um
you can't be thinking about retirement
so it either happens one of two ways
it's kind of you know an epiphany like
all of a sudden i'm just not into it
anymore or
you have something happen like with you
where you know some people it's a it's
more ba it's maybe joint or a knee or
whatever and you have blood clots and
like all of these things are
physiological that you can't do anything
about and so i think that's a lot of
times how a career
ends for an athlete it tends to always
feel a little sudden because you can't
anticipate the moment you don't want to
play in anticipation you're playing all
in
but you've got the job of being a
basketball player and all the things
that go into that um but then you talked
about now you're like my job now i'm a
dad and so i'm kind of curious like
because those are i mean they're both
jobs for sure but you know i'm guessing
that there was that point in time when
you were playing i don't know if you had
all five of your kids while you were
playing or not but i'm sure you started
to have a couple of them like you know
the
the job of basketball played the played
the primary role and now you have like
solid job of being a dad and that's your
your your main role and so you know what
are the what what did what can you
bridge the gap on because there's not a
lot of basketball players out there but
there's a lot of dads out there right so
like what did you learn from basketball
that helps you being a dad
it's all about teamwork um whether
you're the leader or the follower um in
order to accomplish great things you
have to have a great team be a part of a
great team and
it requires each person
to
facilitate what they facilitate to play
their role and i really got that from
uh
being in basketball i wrote about it in
my book checking your ego
one of the things that that i found
fascinating um in my career
was that i got to take part in a team to
where
i was the third leg of the stool which
is pretty still pretty good
well you know in in when we're all
shooting shots
every basketball player playing boy or
girl out there when they shoot that shot
what are they doing on the on in the
playground or on their backyard
basketball they're counting down
three two one and they're making the
shot if you miss it you redo it
you know and you can't go home until you
make it right can't go home until you
make it now nobody's necessarily making
the defensive play imagining that or
getting that rebound or getting that
block
um in terms of basketball uh but all of
those things happen to me because i made
the sacrifice and we all made the
sacrifice to be part of a bigger team
um so
yeah was i frustrated that sometimes
that i didn't get more shots or
sometimes i felt i was b my greatness
was being overlooked sure you know
that's a part of the human process
but
all in all it was about my goal was to
be a part of a successful team at the
end of the day and i translate that
that's where i kind of
not kind of i bridge the gap uh with my
family because um
you know we all have our roles
we all have our jobs day to day we've
got to meet the requirements you know we
want to be a great family so this is
what we have to do you know we're taking
these holiday pictures let's go
everybody clothes on splatter on yeah
yeah
nine o'clock let's go you know vacation
all right let's go get those bags we
gotta get them checked you know it's uh
tells you how many kids i have so we're
a large team when we move
so
you know it requires organization and
and you know anytime we do something as
a family it's a big
you know it's more than seven people you
know so
we i keep those things in mind and as um
i guess
leading with my wife
um i want to make sure that we're
hitting the marks and making sure
you know we're doing we're supposed to
do with that said i have to make sure
i'm on point you know and i have to have
those conversations with myself every
morning to you know assess where we are
what are we doing for the day
and let's meet those goals today and
then that'll be a good day
yeah what happens when it slips like
because inevitably it does life happens
oh for sure i i we always have this joke
if it's a bad day you know hey go to bed
or something it'll it'll get better
that's good
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot
around the resetting of your of your
energy um i listen to a lot of abraham
hicks and it's always like you know the
sort of you start over in the morning
and it's like you know set the day you
get to you get to start over with your
with your energy and um
it's true sleeping on it's a real thing
yeah for sure i mean you know sometimes
you have to be
rested i mean we can fight our bodies
i'm i'm one of the main culprits of this
i just want to go go go go go
and then i'll hit the wall and then i'll
be mad because i'm not rested it's you
know it's all about finding that balance
um
and that's kind of one of the reasons
why i wanted to fall into
being uh you know full-time dad
full-time father and all that stuff
because
you know i found to be honest it was way
easier playing basketball you know
because
it's what i do
being a dad is what i do
you know playing basketball it was all
about i felt like it was all about me i
have to go to the gym
i need to lace up my sneakers so i can
have a good game tomorrow
you need to be quiet so i can get rest
which is great
people play their role my family plays
their role after that you know during
that time but after that
you know it kind of
it's more of a team thing now you know
now i have to go
to golf lessons and tennis lessons and
basketball lessons and be patient and
pack the lunches and
fours
yeah four
that's a big transition i mean you know
as athletes like i get you know spoken
to about kind of the dynamics within my
life and how things have gone but that's
for sure one of them is like you're so
focused and dedicated on your on what
you're doing
um and you need to be um so what peaked
i'm wondering like what kind of triggers
and what kind of things
what kind of things popped up that
you're like i better deal with this so
this is going to be a problem
well i mean
right away i saw the dynamic of the
household i have three boys and at the
time when i knew i wasn't going to play
basketball anymore
my little ones were babies my twins were
babies but
still i'm i have a brother so i know how
uh you know boys in the household can be
and and how is that
what does that mean i don't i didn't
grow up with boys was that oh it's
rambunctious high energy oh it's like
atoms bumping off of each other it's the
same exact thing
[Laughter]
they're just bigger and growing yeah and
hungry yeah
[Laughter]
but you know for um that was one of the
things that helped
ground me was taking my son to school in
the morning every day he was in the
first grade
and i had i was in the carpool every day
i'm fresh off of not playing basketball
you know we're making this change as a
family
people no doubt they had to have stopped
oh yeah they must have knocked out your
window they must 100
i still get approached today um like oh
yeah you were in the car pool but yeah
we were hearing about you i wanted to
but but even then with my son that
wasn't enough he said you know dad
sometimes we get there early say hey dad
um
walk me to class
okay so i'll walk into class then after
that if the kids aren't and if
everybody's not in school yet uh yeah
pick up that book read that book for me
you know and we did that every morning
you know every morning and so
that kind of got me into a rhythm but it
also showed me being a part of the
community of the school
and this is pretty pandemic of course um
you know um
making sure that my son is getting
education that he needs
having that sense of knowing that it's
bigger than just me it's more
uh than just how i'm feeling or what i
want to do it's about what we want to do
as a collective so for me i need to make
sure that he's in a good head space
you know so he can have a good day at
school
and that was pretty much how i started
my day
personally professionally i didn't know
what was going on i didn't know what i
was going to do
um you know moving forward everything
had happened so sudden but
for sure for sure
that that 40-minute drive to school
reading that book and walking my son to
class that's kind of where i started and
then i came back and would uh uh write
just like journal
you know i did this yeah i did this for
weeks and weeks and months yeah
and that's kind of how um this book came
about because i noticed
when i got home
i would write
for a couple of hours and
i just noticed like man i don't really
like what i'm writing about you know i
don't like these words i don't like you
i don't like this let's change this and
i and that made me realize where i was
mentally and and so you're asking me
that question earlier that was one of
the things i did to help me out i recall
free writing just free write
boom boom boom boom and then and then
you read it not cringe a little bit and
say yeah yeah
okay
let me get more to a mode of
appreciation for the journey as opposed
to being mad that it's over because
that's only a fraction
this life thing is uh much bigger
if you're willing to share like what
were you writing about what were the
themes coming up over and over again
being mad at basketball
yeah being mad at basketball um it
happened just so quickly so suddenly i
was on top of my game i was trying to
redefine who i was
i even talked to pat riley and we were
you know a couple months ago and we were
talking about at the time when
i had to
retire pretty much or you know had to
stop playing
i felt we were a championship contending
team not to say we would have won but
you know when you get there and you're
successful all you know all you got to
do is get back and focus
and you take you know you take what
comes your way
um you know not having that chance i was
a bit bitter at that you know just
having it in so suddenly and but still
feeling and knowing that
i'm one of the best players in the world
for sure top 20.
you know why no no that having to deal
with that i i just had to
go through those things go through those
stages of grief realize where i was and
eventually you know be appreciative of
it you know you were talking about
connections one of me and my close
friends josh mcroberts we both
lost the game at the same time we were
both i think i was 31 at the time he was
like 29
and and you know just to hear someone
you know people would say oh yeah that
guy bye-bye he always getting hurt he
can't help it if he gets hurt nobody
says i'm gonna sign a four-year deal and
be hurt every year and never play
the game that i've always done in my
whole life ever again yeah you know but
that's where we kind of connected
accepting those things and
i realized that that is more often the
fate
of uh of someone in our profession so
you know i was even having a
conversation with a friend i said it
didn't end i was so frustrated said it
didn't end the way that i wanted it to
he said dude it never does
so when he said that i was like
he took all the wind out of my cell
because i wanted to argue
no i
when you're talking to somebody and they
have an issue you should maybe clear up
early on if they just want to vent or if
they want a solution
because yeah you'll probably get a real
answer even if they're like man i just
want to talk and you're like great
because i have the problem where i like
to solve problems and so if somebody
comes to me with an issue i'm like all
right what are you doing about it you
know like
sometimes they just want to get it off
their chest you know yeah and i'm sure
that's where you were at to some degrees
like you know you kind of just want to
get it off your chest and you know you
feel a little trapped in the emotions um
uh actually i have one question before i
ask something a little bit deeper but
you know as a as a sports fan and i am a
sports fan all sports um
you know you look at players and you and
you you know you think are you really
injured
like come on did you stub your toe
because you really need to sit out and
um you know i've judged you know being
from chicago
judged like you know bears quarterbacks
or i've judged you know
um you know the bulls when uh you know
uh
rose was on the team and i was like you
know just like people like that and
you're like oh come on get out there and
play so truly what is the what what
happens that makes a player
not be able to play the game whose
decision is it and how bad is it and is
it a short term yes or is it kind of
like a long term like we can't let this
get worse and i'm sure there's a range
of it but what's the general reason
i think you know well i mean the answer
is different now now you have um terms
like um load management
to where some guys will probably take a
day of rest and not play
um you'll have old school nba players
that will disagree with that heavily
because you know we were all about
pushing through
the pain and all those things
i came to have more of a realization how
much
medicine and doctors play into athletes
once i started having my decision or or
not my my um
what i was going through but i'll put it
to you like this one of my uh i had a
teammate at once upon a time
he um
he he injured his back
and he had you know
surgery on his back years later he has a
toe problem
then he has um surgery on his toe
now
could he have stayed was it the right
procedure that was right for him i can't
tell you but
he
progressed quicker than everybody
thought he would he goes to camp
starts the season gets hurt two months
later
you know now it's nothing that he did i
mean it's
he's just trying to play the game but
his body is telling okay he's you know
something's wrong and then after i've
had another teammate who he kept
breaking his foot
like the metatarsal just would go one
first metatarsal third fourth fifth
right after he broke the other one
you know so sometimes it can just be
this chain reaction that you can never
really come back from and with that said
i mean for me i played with sprained
ankles sprained knees
and then you know i've told people hey
don't wait till you come back
no not you know that's not the case
sometimes you have to make a decision i
mean even for me i tore my groin i told
them tore my abductor muscle in the
pursuit of our first championship
and i didn't tell anybody i just said
okay
you know the doctors told me in three
weeks maybe you can play with pain
that's all i needed to hear because i
had my goals
you know was the best thing can't tell
you we won the championship
i didn't make any excuses i didn't want
to say ah well you know
if i would have been playing if my
leg was i know nobody cares so for me i
had to be you know i had to make that
decision to i guess sacrifice my body a
little bit to go out there
and help this team win and at the same
time you know i had to have that moment
of truth and saying okay no this is this
is this isn't it this our destiny is
winning this thing and i've got to be
healthy or
you know or at least play uh to win you
know is it always ultimately up to the
athlete or does the team make executive
decisions
i think more so now the team is more of
an a
a place to make executive decisions more
so than than before i think before
um you know we've had many athletes
whether
they were mentally not ready emotionally
not ready physically not ready they
played and i think um we've seen some
kind of the detriment um that it could
bring so i think now
um
the league sports i think everyone is a
little more proactive
in trying to preserve health or at least
injuries and not pushing the player too
much
yeah
all right well
that answers a lot of questions thank
you
like a part of that also is motivation
right because like you wanted to win the
championship so like your motivation
exceeded the pain how do you what what
was your motivation let's start there
i'm curious like especially when it
comes to the the saying of
you know are you is it the fear of
losing or is it the love of winning like
if you had to pick one of those to start
with which one would you pick the fear
of losing or the love of winning
i i picked the fear of losing for sure
funny story um i used to play i started
playing basketball when i was like nine
years old
and it was uh you know very historic
place in south dallas uh catholic school
which every saturday they would have
what's called bitty basketball it's a
lead 10 and under biddy basketball
league and if you were any good player
out of dallas you played there it's like
the mecca of youth
uh basketball
and we had a team i was in the fourth
grade i was playing up
and
we would lose
quite often i mean if it was another
team that went 0-10 in the league we
were two and eight because we could only
beat them you know what i mean
and every game that we lost pretty much
and i mean it kind of stayed with me
until around the seventh or eighth grade
i would cry
i would cry i mean
it hurt me
like
just a little like a loss in the family
every time i couldn't help it
and um you know i know my parents were
probably just like you're shaking you're
like ah man man this guy
but that's just
you know i wanted to be like my heroes
um i watched michael jordan win a lot of
championships and he was still winning
and i just wanted just a p is just a
taste
just a little just what is it like on
that small level just as that would be a
great saturday
if we could just win a game you know and
i just put my all into it
and
yeah i guess i learned how
competitive i was and how much i cared
you know and i guess ever since then it
was more so
i love winning don't get me wrong but
yeah that
that fear you know and that's what i
took into
uh my professional career
and i don't want to you know make fear a
negative thing it just is what it is
that fear of losing is like okay
let me watch another hour of film
everybody
you know
let's go back to the gym yeah let me i
always found confidence and preparation
so
i felt if i was prepared if i felt if i
knew my assignment
if i felt i knew i was physically ready
emotionally ready ready to go
um that always gave me confidence and
then there's a motive playing the game
my worries were always in between the
big games playing the beginning is no
problem you know it gets stressful sure
it's playing basketball it's that time
in between where
you know you have to keep it cool and
keep it even for like three days
you know how would your teammates
describe you how would my teammates
describe me i i would love to ask him
that question i guess like even keel
but um
i would hold people accountable um if i
was saying something
i would love just hanging out with the
fellas and and and you know being a part
of the team but i more so like to
participate just a little bit but take
it in more uh and if there was something
that needed to be said i have no problem
saying it and sometimes it would
you know my demeanor might be a little
more enhanced
[Laughter]
but yeah you guys
yeah you got to get the point across but
i always just wanted to play basketball
i always wanted to be a part of a team i
wanted to be
that person that uh guys could
talk to and be comfortable with and and
and know
if it's game time i don't have to worry
about him we already know what he's
going to bring he's going to be
consistent
um you know like not too high not too
low again a chapter in my book
you know all about um doing what's
necessary to be successful so what in
your experience makes a good teammate
and then what are the characteristics of
a of a bad teammate
i'll start with bad teammate first okay
um
if it comes to a point where
they're more so talking about themselves
or even the aspirations are more so what
they want as opposed to
what's best for the team
um that can hurt a team
if um someone one of the easiest things
to do
uh in a team situation is complain about
your role
i i think that's probably red flag
number one if somebody's complaining
about their role in saying that they
could do better than such and such
not saying that they could do but of
course we could all do better they can
do better in their singling out
situations and saying man i should be
doing this
then then you know you gotta watch it um
i've been lucky enough to play with you
know some very consummate professionals
and it was only about one thing
and
yeah the dynamic changes daily
um you might be asked
to do a different role than you did
yesterday because someone is injured
um you know someone's not playing well
you always have to change and and be
like a chameleon like in the approach
right wow um
and i think you know a good teammate
a good teammate is just that person like
yo whatever
whatever it takes for the team to be
successful let's do it if i need to
score more cool
if i need to
mop the floor i'll mop the floor if i
need to be the first one here and the
last one to leave i'll do that too if i
need to put a smile on your face because
you're grumpy today
i'll do that too if i need to organize
a team dinner and get
all of the families together
uh
you know that could be a great thing i
think a great teammate
is always that person looking to uplift
everybody around them
you know
yeah
how much of a role you mentioned like a
team dinner and so one of the next
questions i was going to ask was how
much
how critical you think it is to have
that time and space outside of the court
and outside of the meeting rooms
and
be like friends you know because there's
one thing to play together and it's
another thing to be truly actually
friends and care about each other and
know each other's families and and
invest in each other in a in a deeper
way is that do you think that's critical
and and
and do you think that's critical
i think it's everything
it's a it's a necessary part to team
sports i mean just kind of um
um like so for instance with my family
now we uh
one of our things that we picked up is
eating you know making sure we sit down
and eat dinner together it doesn't have
to be all the time
but when we do it hey i need everybody
we do it you know
mostly every day but just still like
yeah come and eat let me see you eat all
right let me talk about your day what
else is going on as a unit as a group
um
that's i think is is one of the most
important things to do because
i love food i love to cook
you know really and so yeah okay
and so you know it always brings people
together and so
you know that was one of the main things
that i saw that made us successful uh
playing with the heat
um
[Music]
you know having those things saying okay
hey we're going to dinner together
we're going we're going to do this
together we're gonna go and support this
person's charity
um you know hey you know my wife is
having a charity please come along and
you know members will show up we have
good times great dinners those are
the parts when you truly get to know
each other because you know once you're
on the court if if i'm always talking to
you and telling you about your mistakes
you'll eventually tune me out you're
going to not want to hear it but if i
know how to talk to you
if i know how to approach you if i know
what you've been going through and you
can only get that through
these intimate uh settings you you can
talk to each other better because
one one of the things that i found out
especially in team sports they're gonna
there's gonna come a moment in the
pursuit of success where you're gonna
have to sacrifice something
usually it's in the form of your body
you know you're gonna have to jump and
jump
your teammate who is your teammate is
probably going to turn it over and it's
going to be a terrible play and you
can't sit here and be like but what are
you doing you got to get back
you've got to make it up you've got to
dive in the stands
and you can't even think about it
when you see that hesitation that's the
sign of
a team that's not close a team that
doesn't have that connection you know
because
if i'm hesitating if i'm hesitating i'm
losing the other team gets the loose
ball and
you know those are
plays that are lost now you know what i
mean so
you know knowing that we're all going to
make mistakes yeah knowing that we have
to move on to the next
part of being present to be fully
successful in this moment you can't drag
and hold onto things which you know
people don't like that's the main thing
you're going to do right hold on to that
thing and be like when you
did that thing of course no
instead of backing them up that's what
i'm hearing for sure you're gonna blame
them and be like i'm gonna walk down the
court because you know what we wouldn't
be in this situation if you wouldn't
have lost
blaming you but backing up means i ain't
gonna make you look bad i'm not i'm
gonna get it you know i'm on it i'm on
it we can talk about it later and i even
talk to my kids about that too you know
i tell them hey regardless that's our
family motto i've got your back
you know i'm gonna hold you accountable
and i'm we've got to do the right things
and i'm going to tell you if if you're
not on track but i've got your back at
the end of the day and that's all that
matters
what do you think was one of the most um
helpful
uh tools that you learned from a
teammate or a coach that was like
tough love
but love you know because there's a way
you can weave the you know thread the
needle through the middle which is not
comfortable it's not like hey bud gotcha
it's like hey
let's sit down you know what what what
did you what did you learn from what was
the most valuable lesson from from
someone in the sport
this is one of the most uh it's a lot of
valuable lessons one of the main ones um
was i had a um coach sam mitchell
he was a young coach at the time which
we've we've kind of laughed and joked
about this um
he was coaching us i was a very
promising young player
my favorite player um my idol growing up
was kevin garnett he was kevin garnett's
older veteran player that taught him the
ropes
in minnesota then he very quickly became
head coach and so i'm asking him for all
the kg story i want anything kevin
please you know give it to me
but you know fast forward i'm
aspiring to be
a great player making a couple of
all-star games
trying to take that next step and be
that leader on a great team
and one particular time we were in san
antonio and he took me out the game at
the end
and i guess i was you know not playing
very well on offense so
i let that affect what i was doing on
defense and i was
not playing very well on either end of
the floor and he took me out and that
was really the first and the only time
that happened in my career
and and we ended up winning the game i
didn't make a fuss about it or anything
i said okay you know all right cool let
me make sure i'm a be a good teammate he
called me we had a conversation
afterwards and he said you know it's
unacceptable for you to be the best
player with your ball in the hands on
one end of the court and not be the best
player on the other end just because
you're not scoring
or just because
you're not successful on offense
the great players learn how to be great
players you need to be you need to play
defense you can rebound you can help
your teammates you can be enthusiastic
there's so many other things that you
can do other than there's just just this
one thing which is scoring the
basketball you need to look at it in
another way
and it was tough um it was it was a chin
check a little bit i never let it happen
again at least in my mind with that team
i'm sure
i'm sure i still have much uh a lot of
improvements to do but
um fast forward to a situation where i'm
in a game seven
playing against the san antonio spurs
and i'm in foul trouble and i hadn't
scored
and i always tell people this and i have
to just bring it home all the time i won
a game seven in the nba championship for
a back-to-back championship team and i
didn't score
thanks ray allen didn't score either
you know so
and i remember when i got in foul
trouble and it's you know as an athlete
it's kind of like when you're driving
and somebody goes by ahead of you like
oh boy that's that that's not supposed
to happen i was in that moment
and i just heard his words in my ear
just saying you can do so many other
things
stay with it in your mind
stay locked into the game support the
ones that are going right now
you're going to finish this game
separate yourself from the normal person
right now because
frustration
agitation all these
words will start to come in and creep up
and
you know the stage frightness and you
know really freaking out because right
like i was saying you see yourself
hitting that shot or having a
spectacular game and i've had
spectacular games oh yeah and in
basketball you get to hear the fans
and you get to hear them oh yeah
they're grunting
[Music]
i'm messing up
[Laughter]
steak stay calm stay with it and and and
you know i was able
um i recognized um
in the game that i wasn't going to score
and i was just off it was just you know
you know one of the best teams of all
time we're playing against and i'm just
having an off night you know one of the
part of the big three but one thing i
could do
was defend the greatest player you know
to ever play the power forward position
and allow my teammates to be themselves
because i utilized everything that i had
in on making it tough for tim duncan and
and and and with that said he he had
just annihilated me the game before
you know so
i was able just to keep those things
intact and always that always stuck with
me to
you know keep your head uh cool
in in in really really tough situations
that always stuck with me
what happens when you have a total
[ __ ] out there and i know you i know
they happen right there's the guys then
i watch it too like i'm like he's dirty
he's provoking him he's you know cheap
shouting he's you know like there's you
can watch it happening and you're like
man that guy deserves to be like he's
he's you know you it's like the second
retaliation is always the worst it's the
biggest punishment the one poking the
bear is like the one poking doesn't get
in trouble it's the one that retaliates
so what do you do like how do you keep
cool when there's that going on and
especially like sit being on the floor
as opposed to sitting at home on your
floor and watching the tv
it's insane how much more physical it is
i mean
it's hard to have appreciation for how
physical especially when you're talking
about like playoff games and you know
final games you know those are i mean
it's insane
how do you keep cool when there's
because there's also people probably
trying to get in your head you know not
only is it just a physical game of
emotions but there's also like
tactical manipulation i'm sure too how
do you stay cool when that's going on
or for me
yeah i mean yeah you you learn hopefully
um one of my lessons was uh you know
again speaking on uh kevin i had a
confrontation with kevin one game
and he's a notorious trash talker at the
time
and i let him get in my head and i'm not
you know or at least i found that i
wasn't that day
i had a really bad game and he played
really good
they wanted dramatic games yeah it makes
it worse and i found myself in a part
where i couldn't sleep like
it was just
i couldn't sleep
for weeks and um
and i said okay the things that were
said the words that were exchanged it
became about more than just the game
it's just about the game
and you know
yeah and you know to add on top of that
i i should have known better but you
have those lessons right i learned from
that i learned that
let me stay focused and talk about
basketball now if you know there's a
dirty player or something like that and
you know
this was the way i was raised playing
basketball i grew up uh playing on the
playgrounds you're going to have those
moments where someone tries to bully you
uh i went to lincoln high school
in south dallas texas you have to be
intense you have to be rough you have to
have a chip on your shoulder to a
certain i don't all the way agree with
that um
lingo but you know what i mean you have
to have
that confidence and you have to bring it
yeah and so you know i have
yeah and i've i eventually developed
uh a sense of all right i'll defend
myself but if we're playing basketball
yeah let's play basketball and if we you
know if if it wants to get a little more
physical good thing i lifted waste this
this off season good thing this is what
i do because i knew this was going to
happen i knew you were going to be dirty
i knew you were going to be physical but
you know all right cool yeah yeah
somebody could be talking to me and i
just look at him like all right cool
keep it up
i want to hear you talking that same way
in the fourth quarter you didn't let
them win
oh no we're gonna i'm gonna put a pin in
this and then oh we can talk later too
i'm i'm not just gonna you know sit here
and take it and just be oh no we're
gonna you're gonna respect me because i
you know love this game i'm strong i'm
strong mentally and i feel that we have
the best team and that's what it's about
competing right now and i'm going to
compete at the highest level and then
after that if you want to shake my hand
that's great but you will respect it and
i had to
you know me being more of a skinnier guy
you get that growing up people are going
to come and try to beat you
you know if you have
some sort of perceived weakness
yeah you know you're going to be
challenged and that's okay you know yeah
sometimes
that's what manipulation is that's you
know that's what getting into someone's
head is about it's like i know what
might make them a little irritable i
know what might make them feel a little
self-conscious did you have rules i
don't i don't know if there's and maybe
you didn't but like is there any kind of
rules that you had for yourself along
the way that you're like look i'm not
gonna let this go past you know i'm
gonna give myself two hours after the
game or i'm gonna give myself like were
there any rules or like hey i'm going to
let them chip at me or elbow me three
times and then
you know did you have any kind of rules
of engagement
i always uh considered
yeah i always consider myself an artist
out there on the court so it just
happens
it you know i guess it's all how i feel
some days you don't want to take any you
don't take no [ __ ]
you know i feel like
my grandma my grandma my great grandma
said don't take any wooden nickels
you're giving me wooden nickels right
now
get that out of my face
what's a story of a
masterfully like executed
mind game
that you played where someone is kind of
getting at you
you're whether you're having a good or
bad day but like what is one of these
games where you're like man that could
have gone a different way but i freaking
nailed it
[Laughter]
i think um specifically one time i won't
name who the player is but um well
you're on the verge yeah we're on the
verge of clinching a championship
and um
our goal is to win one more game and
we i mean it's been physical the whole
time they probably thought that they
could be more physical and out
and get in there but we had been doing
this for weeks two about two weeks and
um we're on the precipice of uh
of a championship and so this would have
been finals and this would have been
yeah oh we're gonna last two weeks yeah
yeah we're in the finals
got it we're in the finals it's winning
this
this is it you know forget tomorrow we
gotta win today
and
there was a moment very very early in
the game where you know we got into a
confrontation
and you know i i i wanted to talk i had
been tired of hearing talking the whole
time everybody talking
and yeah i just had to let them know how
i feel but i left it at that you know
what i mean i wasn't disrespectful i
left it at that we had probably a
30-second exchange and i went right back
to doing what it is that i'm supposed to
do but i didn't try to get back at that
person by scoring on them or making it
look bad
let's continue to have our onslaught
you know directed as a team
and let me play my part and then there's
a reason why i'm talking to you because
i'm tired you talking
[Laughter]
like man you know i had to let them know
like hey after today the season will be
over for you you can have plenty of time
go talk to somebody else don't talk to
me man i'm out here we're about to beat
you you're about to lose and it is what
it is now's not the time you should have
done that
a week ago sure i tried to do that two
weeks ago now and usually what i find
i think um
arthur ashe had a quote um of saying how
he's more so him against himself because
if he's
continuously competing
if you're playing against that person
that's just trying to get in your head
and you not only are answering the call
but it's getting better and better and
better as time goes on because that's
what you train yourself to do
then you watch them lose it that's the
best part
you oh man you watch them fall apart and
it's like oh wow you know i i think i'm
a funny person so i try to
try to use it as material now i'm
getting under your skin now how do you
like it you know oh yeah you just love
it totally you can get under people's
skin by just not reacting because
they're trying to get a reaction for
sure and that's what i had to notice
like oh you just need you need me to say
something to you and after a while i
again garnered the respect of certain
players i'm not gonna
that's what he wants he wants me
to engage with him so he can be get that
thing to be great
you on the other hand no no no
you have to pick and choose right what
about a turnaround because there had to
have been guys that turned it around i
mean they said you know you say like
people are the same you know people
don't change kind of thing but i don't
agree with that i think that there's
there's always there's there's always an
opportunity and i think there are
definitely people that do change and
evolve and
i'm curious if you were if you witnessed
any of that and and what what was what
were some of the things because look i
mean we're all human and we all make
mistakes and so we can all be better and
what what we're you know what what did
they do that made you go okay i respect
you now
i'm gonna have to pat myself on the back
on that one um only because
yeah only because um losing the game so
early so quickly
and you realize that the game goes on
you know as as um great a career as i
had it's just
it goes on there's going to be another
player there's going to be another
situation what i've done
is in the history books
you know being going from the greatest
heights and it again all being about
me in the pursuit of things and some
people can be selfish in those pursuits
and say hey i've got to go and be the
greatest basketball player i can be
but
i've had that time now it's time for me
to like i said before pack those lunches
help pack the lunches bring them make
sure everybody's got their backpacks got
their water all right let's go to
practice
that's me now and i have to believe in
that greater good that is a step towards
greatness
um even if you can't see it at the time
you have to mentally
project what you want to do put in the
work we always say that around here all
the time put the work in
and that's what it's about so i only i
only say that because it was such a
tough transition
of
coming from being a basketball player
only because you don't realize it how
much you're catered to until you're done
playing
you know i'm like man wow
i'm going to the notary today
you know i'm getting keys made we're
going grocery shopping and dropping kids
off at school like
you know your defense mechanisms start
kicking in like what happened to you you
used to be
even people kind of
you know it's interesting people say oh
chris what are you doing nowadays
you'd be surprised dude
[Music]
you'd be surprised and again i know i
have a lot of kids but i have a
professional life as well
and you know trying to keep that afloat
and keeping
our family name strong and
well-represented those things take time
and it takes work and so when i'm
watching and i see these uh masterful
plays that almost look like
how did anyone know the ball was coming
to them like how do you know i mean
there's like no look passes there's
somebody just running and they catch it
midair and duncan at the other end and
like there's just things happening and
you're like you weren't even looking
like how did that happen and there's no
way they can all be plays
is that true they're not all plays right
not all the time it might start like
that but then they have like your you
you always have to play off of what the
defense is doing before you can make a
play
that's what makes basketball such a
wonderful and really just sports i love
sports it's uh it's modern day theater
yeah um
it's
if i were a coach i would try my best to
coach my team into
just being intuitive playing with each
other within a system
but if you zig i know you're zigging if
you're going to zag i know it you know
it takes repetition you have to go so
like be yourself out there so you know
what someone's going to do so what i
really want to know is how do those
plays happen like
how does it happen where it's just this
you know it's the sports center and then
on that play and yeah no there's things
happening that just seem beyond
beyond a play they are almost like
telepathy on court
[Music]
i think again that comes through
repetition doing the same moves over and
over and over watching the same
situations um
and you know you can't control when they
happen i i know a bunch of times for me
i would try to read in patterns i've
researched it um that chess players do
the same thing
they've they've
memorized so many great games and so
many just just a pattern right there and
they'll see it and it's stored somewhere
in the subconscious and they just do the
patterns and then
you know there is a mode of letting the
body take over letting the subconscious
letting those artistic
things develop and just come out of you
and that's where you get that no look
thing and you're asked to
you know with all due respect to people
that ask a question what were you
thinking i don't like that question you
i wasn't thinking you're in that place
between
conscious and not thinking
that's where you want to be you want to
be totally in the moment because i can
read a play
and then i can have 12 different
scenarios come through my head because
i've got you know the five man on the
same side as me the one and two and
three is over there i'm the four
oh wow this would be interesting if this
happened all right then the play happens
and
some things happen you're looking for
certain cues and then you might get them
you might not but it's the reading and
reacting in real time that i just think
when that's just together it's just
beautiful and then that's what i love
about the sport of basketball when you
have
someone or a team just working on all
cylinders
i mean you know it's uh it's great
it's great to watch
i'm i mean this is
a fascinating answer because of what i'm
hearing is it's basically like
i don't know it's almost like getting
the thinking mind out of the way which
is interesting because there's plays
right so there's some something to
execute it's but it's actually in the
in the feeling and the reading the
situation and acting intuitively and
being natural and being yourself
that you end up with those magical plays
for sure uh one of uh the things i read
a um
an old uh japanese samurai book called
the way in the power
and it had a technique
in there that i really really felt and
gravitated towards called motion
and um i'm sure the japanese word has
its own meaning
i don't even think you probably could
even translate it into english but
essentially the essence of it is
attacking with no mind
so
not only
preparing yourself for those moments but
allowing
your body just to do its thing and and
be comfortable in being in the present i
think that's um that's where you get
those
those things that you know the those
sports center plays those
amazing things and sometimes when you
ask somebody how'd you do that
i'm sure you know from experience you'd
be like i don't know
i just did it
it was the right thing to do i love
spirituality and reality and the nature
of reality and how things work and like
can you does that do you pull that over
into regular life
oh for sure for sure um
just having those moments of um again we
talked about photography earlier
uh if my
you know kids are playing outside my
wife i might be like
deep into something and my wife might be
like hey we're planting flowers
outside all right cool i'm gonna grab my
camera and go
you know i'm not really thinking about
it
even the settings on the camera i'm not
even thinking about that either just
what looks good and
you know hopefully it'll be something
later but
staying totally in the moment
uh appreciating that moment
appreciating the flower maybe smell the
flower you know smell the roses right
um look at the color appreciate those
things that
those are the things that i'm working on
now that um you know you know i really
really love even
with us being in the holiday season um
you know the pandemic happening
i haven't seen my family i got to see my
aunt she's uh 80 years old now
and you know we're just talking about
family history i want to know where i
come from and i want to know how it was
when you were my age
she was dealing with segregation
she was a police officer as a woman
wow
in the pudding
dallas police department
in the 70s and 80s
i said are you crazy
now you know some stories about that
bravery is in your blood oh yeah
you know and and and you know you get a
better sense of who this person is yeah
having the confidence to do that make a
bold decision
uh um
for both herself and her family in in
the pursuit of a better life you know
for you know because for my ancestors
just that's how it was we just wanted to
have a better life we just wanted to
have more access we just wanted to be
successful so you know being in the
present really helps me
um do those things because usually it's
easy to say i'm too busy i'm famous i've
got stuff to do
i'm sorry grandma i'm sorry auntie and
then you'll
you know
probably you know regret those decisions
later so
yeah i do my best i'm not saying you
know i'm the best but i do my best to
have some presents about me and know
that
it's not about me if my son
comes and wants to play chess
which
don't give me
he beats me sometimes he blows my ass
you know on most days and i'm losing to
a nine-year-old it's it's a it's an ego
check a little bit but
not for him
not for him it's building up him you
know but for me it's building on me too
because i'm like okay all right cool let
me let me give some strategy together
let me
let me do this but more importantly let
me spend time with my son
oh man happiness
um of course uh we always want to
instill a sense of happiness a sense of
purpose
um having your thing that you
are passionate about and going after
uh compassion
uh we want all our children to be
compassionate
and um you know to
to to really be compassionate about your
your teammate the person to your left
the person to your right have your
sisters back have your brothers back
make sure that you are protecting each
other
um
and then you know just really just
preparation as they get older just
preparing them for what's out there and
preparing ourselves too um but
um you know that's one of i think since
the pandemic happened um and it's
happening we
have really really found a sense of
self in our family
you know learning how to coexist around
each other because everybody can't do
that
um learning how
watching them
you know to hear
unfortunately some parents say ah the
kids nowadays right you always get that
the thing the kids nowadays but to watch
you know they don't go outside anymore
they're on their devices but to watch my
kids
play a game that they just totally made
up and they're all playing together
you know that's um that's just such an
amazing thing to watch them jail as a
unit
uh because i tell them all the time you
know
we have we have to have each other's
back
because out there in that world
nobody ever not and not everybody has
your best intention
yeah man and you're trying you know
yeah you find your tribe this is your
tribe right here this is our tribe and
there's no other better place there's no
other better tribe to be a part of than
this one and so we try
to instill that in them on a daily and
on top of that yeah be active
have your pursuits play you know play
some games have some friends and you
know just enjoy this life all right well
now let's fast forward like i don't know
maybe like 20 years how old is your
what's your age range of kids what's the
oldest and the youngest
13 to 5. okay so let's say yeah let's
say 20 20 years from now 30 years from
now how do you ho how do you hope that
your kids
would describe you
as dad
i want the easy simple things as dad i
want them to be to feel like they can
talk to me
about anything if they choose to
and they know they can go to dad for a
good home-cooked meal
[Laughter]
i think um you know and to know again
that's that's our motto so i know they
had that i have their back and i've had
it
um
i think that's what's most important um
as they get older yeah 30 years from now
if they say that then oh man you know
that'll be uh great for me of course i
have ambitions of
wanting to be successful as a person
holding not holding them to that
standard but for providing that standard
of what's possible because i know
they're gonna far exceed
whatever it is that i do or i have done
if they want to but just to have that
marker and say all right cool i just
want to be a decent example to say okay
when they're having trouble when i'm not
there they can
hopefully
you know remember that time or oh well
you know dad did this or dad did that
but at a very like cellular level
yeah i can talk
he's gonna be my dad
and man i'm gonna get something good to
eat
fed on an emotional level and a physical
absolutely and maybe get a couple good
old stories about the you know the old
days when i was younger some stuff like
that and and learn some stuff that's
kind of what i'm trying to get from my
family now as they get older it's just
hearing those human stories we're all
human
you know hearing that time of yeah when
you were
uh struggling
or when you didn't know what to do right
that's most of the times when we want to
express ourselves or when we want to
talk and try to figure out what it is
that we're doing
um
you know to have some content there as
well because i think
sometimes we can always get into a mode
of
i'm the two time champion you can never
you know
you can never get that i don't want that
to be i want them to know that
everything is attainable they put their
mind to but most importantly
have your own voice and do the things
that fulfill you
and you know somewhere in between that
we can connect um on a father and a
child you know relationship and then as
they become adults change with them be
used to them
you know changing as an adult as an
adolescent as a teen just go on the ride
with them
well said because you know i think
there's a lot of times where you're in
families where people like are i think
there's a pressure to stay the same like
oh what you think you're better than me
now or you know it's like grow and
evolve together and i think that's
beautiful the only other thing i'm
wondering is if you need wine at that
table
when you're feeding them because i make
some and if you need some i could
probably oh
have some to
give look if you know
i'm not in i don't i don't know
everything but if i would have known
that i would have had a glass right here
absolutely we love wine we would love to
have some of your wine absolutely i
would love to send you some so when
we're done
we get a shipping address adam easy
that's easy absolutely we'd love to
support too
thank you i appreciate that well you've
had a phenomenal career you have an
incredible reputation i feel like after
this you know your nba championships and
gold medals it's like those are
wonderful but you're even more wonderful
which is you know why you have the
reputation you do and i'm sure that's
why you've accomplished what you have so
um thank you for sharing with me but
then of course like sharing in your book
these these gems of of of learning that
you know come the hard way that
hopefully you can give some people
advice to shortcut some of the
shortcomings but people look up to you
and um
you do a great job with them so thank
you i appreciate that thank you very
much i appreciate it same to you
congratulations on everything you're
doing it's awesome the book and this
podcast i mean it's heard around the
world that is uh such an incredible
thing congratulations on that thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button